les sites chances qu'une dernière grande
ville disputée dans la région buluan sq
est à feu et à sang bâtiments et maisons
sont calcinés d'intenses combats se
tiennent depuis des jours la sau et
violent moscou souhaitant la prise de
cette ville clé
et c'est ce qu'ils revendiquent
désormais la russie et même sur aude ne
sait à quoi nous aspirons tous depuis
huit longues années est arrivé
aujourd'hui nous avons libéré la ville
de lys teachers qui est dit ces chiffres
et ces parades saison cette avancée
notable est célébrée par les russes qui
contrôle la moitié d'une basse ces
images le confirme on y voit des soldats
visiblement fier ou encore cet homme le
vin un drapeau russe sur son balcon dans
une publication sur facebook l'armée
ukrainienne confirmé avoir retiré ses
soldats pour préserver des vies
reconnaissant la supériorité militaire
de l'ennemi mais la situation demeure
confuse à preuve selon le président il n
ce qu' il est impossible d'affirmer que
les sites chance qui sous contrôle russe
toujours dans l'est à quelques
kilomètres de la ligne de front des
frappes sur flu viennent ce qu'on fait
six morts et 15 blessés dont un enfant
selon le maire de la ville mavs des
beaux jours des dizaines d' incendies se
sont déclarés notamment dans ce marché
le vient ce qui est sous forte pression
russe certains la qualifient de
prochains lieux de batailles
même chose akram à tort sq plus au sud
tôt ce matin des bombardements ont
d'ailleurs retenti sans faire de victime
des infrastructures civiles ont
néanmoins été lourdement endommagée du
côté russe moscou accusé kiev d'avoir
tiré des missiles à belgorod près de la
frontière tuant au moins quatre
personnes ici et me lemieux radio-canada
à montréal